et un an de l'élection présidentielle
quel bilan donc dressé de l'élection du
président sur le volet sécuritaire mnm
la croix qu'il échoué sur la sécurité où
il est trop tôt de le dire c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler raphaël gauvin
député la république en mars 5ème
circonscription de saône-et-loire
bonsoir raphaël gauvin merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés pour débattre belle et
les boyer sénatrice les républicains des
bouches du rhône
bonsoir valérie boyer merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france annonce
donc de renfort à aujourd'hui encore
message de soutien aux forces de l'ordre
qui en ont bien besoin au 4e mandat
quel est le bilan du président les
violences et les actes de sacs
d'insécurité sont-ils moindre ombre eux
dans le pays raphaël gaume un mois je
tenterai maryse brouillette une autre
question alors je la répète avec plaisir
annonce de renforts on a vu un coup de
communication diront certains du
président de la république aujourd'hui
clairement il ya t'il un mieux sur le
front de l'insécurité en france
aujourd'hui après quatre ans de mandat
emmanuel macron le client la sécurité en
face et de le débat de ce soir là la
sécurité a été au coeur du programme
présidentiel et elle est au coeur depuis
2007 dos de notre action vrai vous avez
rappelé dans votre dans votre porte à
ces dix mille policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires
on a fait à peu près la moitié là il ya
des annonces supplémentaires
l'opposition dénonçait que c'était juste
des effets de com mais c'est de l'action
c'est des choses très concrètes
je vois moi par exemple amazon c'est
dans les annonces du président c'est
demain c'est ce policier de plus qui
vont arriver c'est des policiers en plus
c'est des moyens aussi en plus le budget
sur en matière de sécurité que ce soit
intérieure ou justice augmenté de de
plus d'un milliard depuis 2010 est le
budget de la justice qu'on a voté
l'année dernière c'est plus lui % 8 %
qui va être pour l'essentiel consacré à
rénover rénover des tribunaux rénover
les prisons qu'il ait plus de deux
places supplémentaires
et puis le bilan de notre action c'est
aussi une adaptation constante de nos
moyens juridiques pour rendre notre
légiste
beaucoup plus opérationnels pour lutter
contre la délinquance
vous pouvez rire mes chers collègues
mais c'est la loi site que l'on va
revoir dans quelques mois c'est la loi
contre la sécurité globale qui renforce
qui donne plus de moyens juridiques aux
policiers municipaux sais c'est
l'ensemble de ces mesures qu'il faut que
bien sûr que les choses sont pas
parfaites
bien sûr que j'entends les yaka fokon il
est toujours plus qui propose des
référendum ou des mesures qui ils le
savent eux mêmes ne sont absolument pas
opérationnel
eda et quant à eux étaient aux affaires
ont baissé les montants qui était dédiée
à la justice le rappel sous nicolas
sarkozy t'es pour peuvent leurrer voilà
et ans lors du débat si nicolas sarkozy
ces dix mille policiers en moins sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy sous le
quinquennat de deux des manuels macron
ce sera dix mille policiers
supplémentaires valais les voyez votre
réponse est vrai que cette critique elle
revient elle revient souvent sur le sur
le mandat sarkozy
le nombre de policiers qui ont baissé
oui je rappelle que le niveau de
sécurité sous nicolas sarkozy et le
niveau d agression sous nicolas sarkozy
a baissé de façon très significative
alors qu'il avait augmenté dans le monde
à dieu n'existe pas et que depuis trois
ans que manuel mc ren est en place le
goût citer un chiffre pour par un brevet
de chiffres les téléspectateurs mais il
faut savoir que les violences aux
dépositaires des forces de l'ordre c'est
une centaine par jour soit + 21 % et moi
je me réjouis de voir que emmanuel
macron va mettre en place des policiers
c'est moins de 1% du plan de relance qui
est consacrée à la mise en place de
policiers pour l'instant on est loin du
compte
et si loin du compte des promesses et si
on fait le parallèle
avec ce qui se passe pour les places de
prison je rappelle que dans la
république avait promis pendant un petit
problème un petit problème voilà de
réseau avec valérie boyer
malheureusement raphaël bovins une image
qu'on retiendra quand même cet après
midi c'est celle d' emmanuel macron qui
a embarqué avec une équipe de la bac 1
pour faire le tour des points de vente
de drogue dans la ville de montpellier
au même moment il ya eu un échange de
balles dans la ville un homme est entre
la vie et la mort ce soir à ce que ce
n'est pas la lex cruelle illustration de
ce qui se passe communication d'un côté
et principe de réalité du terrain de
l'autre il ya et notamment depuis le thé
confinement et on voit au niveau local
et moi j'ai des fut aussi sur ma
circonscription il ya une augmentation
extrêmement fort des violences physiques
notamment des violences contre les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
c'est un phénomène qui qui est pas
limitée juste à la france alors les
causes sans doute une banalisation de la
violence notamment avec les les réseaux
sociaux c'est quelque chose sur lequel
il faut qu'on agisse et c'est pour ça
que les annonces ont été faites d'un
renforcement pour qu'ils aient plus de
policiers sur le terrain
et puis surtout c'est pour ça que on a
mis en place des dispositions pour
renforcer les les peines et notamment
les peines encourues contre les auteurs
de violences contre les forces de
l'ordre sorte heureusement récupérer
alors j'ai pas entendu tout le débat
mais je voudrais terminer sur ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est compliqué
quand même de croire emmanuel macron
parce que déjà c'est lui qui a dit sur
un réseau social qui a parlé de
violences policières donc c'est quand
même un message qui est d'une grande
violence et d'une grande défiance vie
lee des forces de l'ordre est ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que il peut pas y
avoir et là je pense que nous sommes
tous d'accord de sécurité si le
continuum police justice n'est pas
respectée or aujourd'hui on a les plus
grandes difficultés avec les
constructions test de prison ce sont des
difficultés pour la dignité des
personnes incarcérées mais en soucier
des difficultés pour la sécurité des
français
et quand dans la campagne présidentielle
emmanuel macron avait promis seize mille
places
ensuite il a revu ses prétentions à la
blesse 7500 places en 2018 que 4500
places en 2019 aujourd'hui on en a que
1500 en plus donc on voit bien que si on
peut pas demander aux policiers et s'ils
sont plus tant mieux compte tenu de
l'augmentation de la sécurité de faire
leur boulot si c'est pour relâcher ou ne
pas incarcérer les personnes qui sont
condamnées
je rappelle qu aujourd'hui 45% des
personnes condamnées à de la prison ne
le sont pas ne sont pas en prison six
mois après leur condamnation
donc on toutes ces difficultés sont
majeurs on les a souligné on a fait des
propositions très importantes et je
voudrais illustrer mon propos par la
sinistre histoire qui est arrivée à
l'âge analystes 17 ans qui a été violée
par quelqu'un qui devait être en prison
et qui n'a pas effectué la totalité de
sa peine
donc aujourd'hui et les parents ont
porté plainte contre l'état et je les
comprends et je les soutiens dans cette
démarche parce que on ne peut plus
accepter ça la justice est rendue au nom
du peuple français
et ces personnes qui sont dangereuses
pour la société je rappelle quand même
que son agresseur avait avait agressé
son conjoint qui avait lu cent jours de
dit était ce un jour du tt je préfère
même pas pensé l'état dans lequel cette
pauvre dame à pouvait se trouver
donc aujourd'hui on voit bien que ce
continuum est rompu et qu'il ya un
problème de confiance dans l'application
des peines et moi j'entends tout ce que
le ministre de la justice dit mais j'ai
participé au texte sur le séparatisme
comme celui sur la sécurité globale et
je note que nombre de propositions que
nous avons faites n'ont pas été entendus
par le gouvernement
alors moi je
réjoui du fait que nous ayons plusieurs
des policiers supplémentaires même si
j'attends vraiment de voir si cette
promesse sera tenue
ce que je constate de façon tout à fait
concrète c'est que sur l'équipement des
policiers qui est quand même majeur
parce que nous avons par exemple
beaucoup plus de policiers par habitant
qu'en grande bretagne mais leur
équipement en france est quand même
défaillant et bien que là le budget a
baissé donc il faut de la cohérence à la
fois sur l'équipement des policiers sur
leur affectation
aujourd'hui on a des policiers qui sont
là pour vérifier si on a bien rempli nos
attestation qu'ovide et si on respecte
le confinement par deux pardonnez moi
parce que c'est ça il faut laisser le
temps de la parole aussi fait le cover
justement est-ce que voilà l'uniforme on
va changer apparemment d'uniformes ce
que c'était bien l'urgence aujourd'hui
dans ce débat sur sur la sécurité en
france c'est vrai que ses critiques sur
le laxisme de la justice ça revient
extrêmement souvent est-ce que c'est pas
là qu'il faut agir en priorité essayer
de faire peut-être tous les deux s'il
vous plaît des réponses portent travail
de longue haleine de très longue haleine
et il faut évidemment renforcer les
moyens les moyens de la police mais
également les moyens d'acheter et ça
passe par un nombre grandissant de
construction de places de prison
on l'a voté je te rappelle + 8 % dans le
budget les liens dans le budget de cette
année qui sera consacrée pour
l'essentiel à la construction de
nouvelles généraux et de ses joies mais
on est très loin de la construction
dépasse de prison et aujourd'hui c'est
un problème de dignité pour les
personnes incarcérées
mais c'est aussi un problème de sécurité
pour les français comment pouvez-vous
aujourd'hui dire aux français que les
personnes n'existent les peines ne sont
pas exécutés parce qu'il n'ya pas de
places de prison d'une pas ou que
certains ou certaines personnes n'ont
pas fait leur peine dans leur totalité
ou même dans la moitié de la totalité
compte tenu des réductions peine parce
que head risquer d'attraper le collier
dès qu'elles ont commis des crimes et
des délits par des personnes sur des
personnes pour des français
alors qu'elle devait être en sécurité
alors que ces personnes devaient être
hors d'état de nuire
donc moi je jeu j'espère vraiment que
ces policiers supplémentaires vont
arriver mais jusqu'à présent je constate
qu'on a eu des annonces qu'on est à un
an pile de des présidentielles et que
j'ai plutôt l'impression de voir un
plaisir la république en campagne avec
un bilan sur le plan de la sécurité qui
est quand même très très mauvais compte
tenu de l'augmentation des atteintes aux
personnes compte tenu des manifestations
qui ont eu lieu tout au long du mandat
de d'emmanuel macro et compte tenu aussi
du fait que les agressions aux
détenteurs de l'autorité publique n'ont
cessé d'augmenter
les policiers ont été victimes de
violence et c'est le président de la
république lui même qui parle de
violences policières ça c'est
inadmissible mais je vous assure que
demain je participerai aux
manifestations devant la préfecture de
police pour m'insurger face aux peines
qui ont été prononcées vis-à-vis des
policiers qui ont été attaqués en
banlieue parisienne et brûlé je peux pas
répondre
est ce que vous pouvez me laisser parler
paraît bon geek sur les chiffres c'est
totalement faux
encore une fois on a voté une
augmentation ont été dirigés va
permettre la construction de plusieurs
prisons ce que vous dites sur les
éléments
si vous êtes sur le terrain moi j'étais
la semaine dernière à l'agenda ou shana
et je peux vous dire que l'augmentation
des crédits qui a permis l'arrivée des
nouveaux véhicules
c'est quelque chose c'est quelque chose
qui arrive car et qui est au chrtr donc
ce que vous dites sur la baisse de
l'augmentation de la dotation pour les
équipes et les équipements c'est un
mensonge c'est pas vrai c'est pas moi
c'est une réalité sur la baisse des
moyens moins 24% pour l'acquisition des
véhicules mois 27 consent pour
l'acquisition des munitions détail des
rôles
deux places de prisons nous sommes très
loin des 16 mille places promises merci
en tout cas à tous les deux par retraite
dans une bataille de chiffres
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué à
vérifier en tout cas on n'aura pas la
réponse ce soir mais on va s'empresser
d'aller défier ces chiffres objectifs
merci en tout cas tous les deux d'avoir
accepté ce face à face est pardonné mots
pour ses petits problèmes de son et de
micros et de réseaux voilà merci raphaël
gauvin et valérie boyer d'avoir été avec
nous